yep ten in five four in five and four
three two one
name the movie three Johnny Cash
no no hunger Paulo get younger
I think planes were lands were fan in
five what's up bring more three so
bright Oh hold on what's up ranks this
is this is Monday yeah you know clincal
Monday don't call me rank such your day
man my name is not ranks dude fighter in
the wrinkled no don't call me rinks you
know I don't like that just like sweet
tart tart and ass this [ __ ] I'm dense
mister death these kinds of things kind
of catch on big gales I don't ask that's
all I get I'm [ __ ] at the club my dad
wants you in Utah minding my own
business and a blonde guy with muscles
and nice hair young kid comes up and
goes gives me a milkshake with
strawberries um and I go what and he
goes this is for your sweet tart man
it's the liver and his friends are
crossbow going yeah I'm like you
[ __ ]
your rings now dude no no man cuz my
skin and admit it my skin is matte best
smooth right now when you shave you look
a little not a little what a little
older older yeah I'm told I look a lot
younger what are you concerned a little
puffy looks older when shades yeah I
think you look better well you have a
little bit of hair on there so that
should be a nice as possible well shaped
here's the thing here's the thing
there's nuts 11 o'clock at night I go
I'm hungry
don't do it Bry oh I know I have a huge
bowl of cornflakes with almond milk and
raw cream late and robbery I'm [ __ ] up
I can't do it why do you do that like
that's why are you 14 not good for you
your boy how many days now I'm 16 days
straight ketose
relooking what are you looking thin I'm
looking bitter look in the space that's
right dude kid are you lifting a lot of
weights it's called anavar Oh just
kidding
wait a minute no you might be cheating
nope you can test me bro
I'll be pulsing these nuts in your mouth
you're gonna try I could you could huh
good dude how about I even stayed Kido a
in Nashville which was a tip of the hat
but last night jo koy asked me to do
shows with him yet chosen brass yes so I
drove down to Brea 60 miles 120 miles
driving yesterday but jo koy had this
chef make like special Filipino food you
don't know he doesn't know big brands
all full team Kido so he has all this
spread rice shrimp all these Rice's this
chef comes in everyone's like whoa whoa
and Joe's all do we're gonna film you
try and Filipino food for this time I go
that sounds fair there's so many people
there and everyone's all excited to see
me try to go that sounds fantastic man
that sounds really cool I can't eat any
of that set for the fish right there you
know what you know I can't have any of
this because it's not keto friendly goes
oh you can cheat one day I go I really
can't because you can cheat on it Joe
I'm telling you I'm like an achievement
so he's like all right so he had this
soup it was like this tumeric yellow
like looked like it was tasty Oh oh my
war my word is right I got those
Philippine I'm the fishes load was a
fish good yeah like a white flaky almost
like a sea bass I don't know I was rice
I love rice I had one more pound of Thai
rice sticky rice yeah yes [ __ ] your
pants no I don't doesn't make here's my
thing I know dude it was so delicious
he's such a good dude man he's the best
jo koy is a great here's that here's why
I wish you would have went with me this
I would have come what's coming down
really I don't have come down on a heart
what's cool to see is the way he runs it
the way cuz at his level he sell more
teeth than anybody we know was that drug
that's right
he sown so many tick yes I can't
announce the deal cell brow probably 15
times
okay hon all right taken equal money
well he sold 16 last year but but it's
the record it's the record SD what seat
600 still out 16 what's the math there
Wow oh they want to do 22 shows but you
don't have time to do 9600 tickets yeah
he won they want to do 20 you didn't
want to do literally 20 something shows
he can't do it so he's only doing 15
this year but they sold out for months
ago anyway so he's selling more teeth
with anyone we don't never give me a
special yeah right
but so when I start doing Filipino humor
oh dude yes sure
but what you should see the way he runs
a man his merch his sister runs it his
merch and he's a DJ on stage it's a
performance man he's so good Deana DJ he
is a DJ that does songs for him when the
DJ like stays there for everyone said
and then once Joe goes on they talk a
little bit riff you know do the thing
then he walks off and then the whole
vibe so good his merch dude best merch
I've seen in any really why yeah he did
some deal with Levi so he has like
Levi's black jackets on the back it has
his like slogan turquoise from the
ghetto to the ghetto where one I'm gonna
get one I'm gonna start wearing my
friends merch
yeah that yeah I'm serious Howard
Delia's over Brogan oh we're all that
[ __ ] so I have that one the middle one
when they get I don't know why they
didn't give me a hat I feel like they
didn't want to give me stuff I gonna be
honest the one guy was like don't know
I'll get you set up because I guess this
is all we have in a excel and it runs
big we are a giant so I know but the
hats are one-size-fits-all you know hmm
I feel like that just up rice is rice
yeah but the way he runs it man so cool
how he runs a tight ship it's so he does
so well and he's always yeah I need I
need to the next time I go on and I need
to start doing merch I'd never do merch
on the road which is so stupid and your
brother was like what are you crowds
older but yeah I hear you and not only
from there all right yeah I know yeah
young and they want mercs
they tell me they want merch yeah I ever
say they're older like that yep
especially when I get my lids done do
but joke I'm telling a joke coordinate
of the right dude [ __ ] a man he just
signed a deal I can't say who it's for
years figure out but
it's a new arena I'm wait for him to say
it but doing the form I mean anything
how I want to do it's all I want to do
he's making the crazy money to stand up
taller one he's a nice guy in the world
and also he doesn't you know there's
some politics and stand-up you know
where this click and this click he
doesn't obtain me now he's friends with
everybody
now and we should all be I mean what is
this what is this [ __ ] oh yeah we
hate certain people but we got no but
I'm here yeah we hate people oh come on
you me we have our clay come on bro
we're a couple Chatty Cathy but we have
our cliques but we don't hate you one
thing about Brennan and I I don't gossip
about anything but when Brennan and I
get together with some Chetty and
another thing and if there's any gossip
I guess I got I heard some interesting
news I tell you but you're a Chatty
Cathy how many times I call it's me
signaling to you I was on set I called
you probably six times seven times I was
calling back Jesus Christ dude I want to
know so badly like what the [ __ ] is
wrong I'll second I go tell me right now
immediately now some juicy info it
wasn't one section if it wasn't that was
I love I love juicy and [ __ ] you see I
got some juicy info on Jeffrey Epstein
is it legit juice well it's from a guy
who knows him who's in the science world
it's from a guy who was asked to meet
with him it's from a guy who's one of
the smartest people I know and does he
have any reason to chase this clout
right absolutely not he said it
privately in a very hot like he said it
privately among like like a group of
people that I have in the business and I
was like what and basically the theory
was that why was Jeffrey Epstein first
of all we don't really have a record of
how he started we we know he dropped out
of Cooper Union
I know all I know is he's a billionaire
so Cooper Union he dropped out of but
there was didn't have he was a math
teacher at Dalton for a while but we
don't have like there's no NBA there's
no how did he become some of this
financier how did he become so close to
Wexler how did it become so close to
these huge names what why was he living
in that the most expensive [ __ ] house
in Manhattan with a heated sidewalk
I who gave them the money where did he
start with this we don't know we just
don't know go to his picture for me he
was a really handsome dude too like a
good-looking you like he was look at him
you guys look like brother well well and
this is where we're getting to look
exactly this is how we're getting this
work guys this is tricky I know it
straight exactly this I know dude but
what the but what's really weird about
it is that we don't know a lot about his
origins right however looked into it so
this scientist I know he was very
interested in science and he said he
supported a lot of scientific
foundations and projects okay
why and one of the things that this
scientist said is he goes I was amazed
at how [ __ ] literate he was
mathematically in Scientology was a
physics and mathematics teacher at
Dalton School yes in Manhattan so
exactly so but the Eddie gray he dropped
out of Cooper Union so what the [ __ ] was
about his visibility to really had a
command not a new stock right like
Finance he knew a lot of this stuff
right so my friend goes my friend goes
to have a meeting with him in his house
sees cameras there but he's like those
cameras are there for me to see him were
there little girls there was a hot
heiress who was in her 20s nothing wrong
with the on his lap dude billionaire yes
but on his lap while he was talking the
long story short is my friend believes
that this guy was a construct what so
well meaning he is not who he was
purporting to be responding he was
probably working for someone like
Israeli intelligence a friend a mean
soldier so why why so he had his own
Island here his own plane why was he so
connected how do you get the most
powerful men how do you the most
powerful men money
he's a bladder how do you get them how
do you get the most powerful men in the
world to be your friend money nah
beautiful women young hot girls who are
willing to have sex with you right I'll
be your how about this though how about
this I'll be anybody why why do you
bring them on your plane why do you
bring them on your island well relax bro
and also it's a controlled environment
so maybe there are a billion cameras
around so maybe
you've got dirt on these [ __ ]
sure yeah so maybe now you're entering
into and when you're when you're knee to
knee and in an orgy with with with your
boys
that's pretty bonding because you're all
implicated now is they're the most
bonding now you're all implicated right
you go through that man okay it's like a
war brother it's a band of brothers need
your knee my knee is on your knee and
we're just going down that's the don't
let me and the I want it but that's
right if your DP and a girl there's nuts
on top of nuts
they're my friend's brother you got to
be good friends smiles all being a UFC
fight together right there you go couple
tours I call it but we're all implicated
now now you got now how about this woman
who they came out and said she had sex
with a foreign president with like a
prime minister these are the most part
from in the world with egos they like
the phone they like to [ __ ] we ain't
[ __ ] we love the [ __ ] correct and these
dudes are I mean if you don't think the
most powerful men in the world are
banging the most beautiful women in the
world there's a you know and I know
there's an underground oh and I got
something else to say I got something
else is he a spy that is the that is
like he needs to be a real rich night
contributes to the campaigns and to
whatever where you get his money why was
he so close to Wexler who owned limited
who owned you know I'm not a conspiracy
theory guy no I know that's what he
owned the limited he owned Victoria's
Secret he's the most he is the most
successful garment toe in the world this
guy Wexler 80 something years old they
had a falling-out about seven years ago
but why was this guy he was his most
trusted confidant why they ran --them
trains
flexo was gay makes it even crazier oh
no they run trains too so the theory is
he was working for an intelligence
agency the theory is he was a spy the
theory is he might have been working for
maybe Israel there's a lot of this [ __ ]
going around today maybe I'm speaking
out of turn but to hear it from the
person that I heard it from who's this
smartest [ __ ] and I hope he comes public
and talks about it cuz he probably will
I think he probably well on Rogen I mean
I was like I know this guy is real and
he's serious and I was like and he's not
usually I'm like this no secular is real
juicy this guy really knows his [ __ ] and
and and was solicit
by Epstein so high for me I'm like a
scientist he's smart as [ __ ] they wanted
information who wants this information
on science why what are you looking for
there's so many these days let me ask
you this there's two sides to this yeah
did Hillary Clinton's people kill him a
trump go I think this is a guy who said
because we know I think we all agreed
and commit suicide I don't know how do
you get into the prison I think he might
have offed himself because there's so
much well yeah but but I think keep any
other cell mate cuz you gotta sell me
you know that yeah baby he's a guy who
said maybe he's a guy who said I I'm
gonna at the end of the day there are
too many secrets and I'm gonna kill
myself because there's a reason to do it
or you can bring the whole boat down
with you and get out or not get out but
at least get he's like a good prison for
less of his life you did add some life
well he would have con your lifestyle
wave done it was he done though yeah I'm
cooking turkey car way but not if you
like dude I've watched Bill Clinton [ __ ]
his seven-year-old there's a chance this
guy was now it was definitely a
definitely into young girls on a perv
definitely in a definitely into young
girls and a perv but you know that's so
so he's he's a guy who was having sex
with I guess you know from what I hear
from 14 to 22 year old girls yeah okay
there's that we need to listen over 20
I'll have a problem now over 20 well 18
is legal so some you know ladies love
creepy even it's my age eighty I like
these guys dude it's technically legal
when you get lower than that although
this is 17 dude for yeah I just think
all these kids are [ __ ] at I get
turned up uh-huh
not a young one Las Vegas that the age
is 17 so you could legally have sex with
a woman at 17 it's when you get under
that and you're you're flying them
places
it's creepy [ __ ] if their 20s flying
around welcome to the real world the
here's the thing here's the thing these
girls are having sex
III I'm curious to see who will find out
that that Clinton and these guys were
having sex with these women on this
plane and there's no an idea norm I like
the island on the planes they have a
bunch of stuff I wonder who else is
involved that I
well who brought the island the island
was living in Wexler's house they don't
have a transaction of the from what I
understand they don't have an ad they
don't have a transaction of of the house
being bought
why was he living the most expensive
house he didn't buy it it's always a
billionaire so he but even the guy oh
yeah five hundred million dollars wasn't
a billionaire he was about worth about
500 milliwatts a lot of money Oh in the
bay yeah that's a lot but also the like
the guy who owns Virgin Records as a
island like you we abide an island you
islands pretty cheap yeah it is funny
look at his Mexican states have a
primary age of consent which may be as
low as 12 so in some countries mxk is
legal it makes you get it together no I
think in Mexico I mean I think that's a
weird we have to be careful with that
statistic but at the end of the day
that's a lot of countries 15 16 you see
it you see it it's crazy the age of
consent in countries of Central America
range from 14 to 18 there you go so how
funny in in South America he's like
you're fine
so you think you aspire there was a
chance though and a lot of this stuff
that he could have in some ways fought
this for a long time or he was a big
flight risk they set bail at crazy
amounts I just think this is a guy who
might have been intelligence operative
who is in the business of getting
powerful men in the compromised
supposition of saying a lot and saying
conspiracy now and said you know what
I'm a patriot I'm killing myself that's
one way to go about it I also think when
you're a billionaire and you're living
in these mansions and this place of
Manhattan they go from there dubbed
prison cell you're like oh [ __ ] oh no
it's done huh you want me to spend the
rest of my you're done I'm used to
busting nuts but I'll see ya that's
locked up in jail to ease your protector
you're living in you know confinement
for the rest your life in you're a
billionaire living in the most exclusive
homes your private jet your [ __ ]
chicks
eating the best food you got the dopest
cakes Yeah right coolest friends you go
from that to being in a [ __ ] cell
he's like oh [ __ ]
Eddie knows he's never getting out Isaac
I'm out dude I'm really curious to see
and why did he why was he able to kill
himself like that here's why wasn't he
monitored what we
sososo did he help why do you guys look
exactly the same
oh that's a different story did he have
help we'll get him later Brian's older
brother but did he have help from a
foreign agency who knows it's really
interesting man I'm actually curious now
and I think we're gonna find out more
yeah
suicide watch I don't know if we'll find
out more I don't think we will we may
not ever it doesn't let us do that stuff
but this this woman Maxwell who's now
being indicted because she was his
Wrangler allegedly I think this is more
than just perversion I think I think
it's a whole ring if you have trip
linear he would unleash on this but I
think it's a whole ring of higher-ups
politicians what a [ __ ] this dude all
of them all all connected they're
busting nuts and little girls I agree
and it is shady [ __ ] well they're
busting nuts in in in like sex trade 18
19 20 year-olds - that you want to get
most powerful men have you say we have
these tens we're 20 they're like they're
really hot and I'll have sex they're
[ __ ] dudes are like I don't give a
[ __ ]
I'll dude if you're a president country
if if William Morris OCA if William
Morris went hey Schwab we got these two
twenty-year old smoke shows come over
here I'm going over this what I'm doing
the one Sam Brennan we're not going over
there you send them over to us honors I
don't know what kind of cameras you have
and I'm just gonna talk them and tell
them not to do this I would have to sit
them down and say young lady
this is not this is a dead end yeah it's
very strange man guards do not check on
Epstein for several hours even though
standard procedure requires a physical
check every 30 minutes it did there's so
much foul play here I'm not I'm not that
big conspiracy theorist either but this
is where eyes come on I never would have
thought this until I had this
conversation this weekend
and and I was at dinner Saturday when I
wanted you to come and that was one of
the reasons I wanted to come because you
would have been you would have been like
people at the dinner table were like
this they were like they literally were
like they're mud and I had some
intelligent people at table they were
like they were looking at him like this
what the [ __ ] and and even I'm me too
and I was like you know me with I always
think it's all [ __ ] conspiratorial
conspiracy theories foreign intelligence
agencies
very organized do you know what the do
they know what the [ __ ] they're doing
and this doesn't add up this this makes
no sense it does make sense that a
foreign intelligence agency would want
to get compromised a bunch of wealthy
powerful men for information for favors
or whatever that makes helpful a bro
mm-hm dad I was gonna go to Charles
Manson exhibit they actually thought
that anniversary of the murders was
yesterday I was gonna this exhibit
downtown LA but I decided to jo koy
shows instead I was themed dice I don't
have one friend a call to go with me who
would go to that with me I would would
you go to it hmm I love that so I feel
creepy about it like you're reading that
book you've been putting some reading
down I'm very impressed
yeah well I'm on the road I saw it is
real of that I do I tried to finish a
book in a week now I love hearing that
that's that's incredible it makes such a
difference doesn't it oh yeah just
really your vocabulary and your thinking
yeah I mean just reading I mean you just
I wish I wouldn't I was younger I put
more of an emphasis on books like we all
do die we all just don't [ __ ] we all
say stupid when you're when you're
yelling like oh what the [ __ ] the cool
the cool thing to do is to go to an
audible.com they have the great courses
and you can like listen to it as you're
driving you this and a half hour lecture
oh it's cool there's no a whole [ __ ]
course on philosophy history or whatever
they and you get a lot out of it I've
got so less the Charles Manson exhibit
mmm just say it's done I think just that
5 p.m. was the last time it was done my
mom would love to go to this this is on
LA Times just talking about the exhibit
three thousand square foot collection
there's a this and now I'm not big
conspiracy theorist either there's a lot
that goes in this Charles may have the
stuff do that's the book I mean with the
CIA and the way this was the media and
the propaganda with this like it's well
Nixon's chief of staff so Carr Larson
who has got this
he's the Navy sealed for 14 years and he
was a vice war correspondent he just
sold us show to Netflix I hope I can say
this but it's about it's about narco
trafficking and stuff and one of the
things he said is during the war on
drugs
Nixon's chief of staff dis again I'm a
little naive to how bad people are
Nixon's chief of staff
said essentially we couldn't outlaw
hippies or blacks so we went after them
we haven't went after the drugs they
used yeah weed for hippies okay and and
I can and heroin for blacks and so that
that was the war on the war on drugs was
really a war on blacks and a war on
subversion so there was a there was a
yeah there was a sort of idea that these
people are gonna become communists or
socialists so we have to [ __ ] [ __ ]
them so what is this chin it's just the
exhibit to say if it's still open I'm
looking at the scroll up and right stay
right there says but the most troubling
items of the manson room are the crime
scene photos taken after family members
murdered three women of four men on two
day rampage in august Sharon Tate yep
know that the Fatah the photographs
shows sprawled corpse and others prepped
with knife I had so much blood so much
but the crime-scene photos are they
paused this field like a long time very
intense they're uncensored I like seeing
that stuff it traumatized me but I'm
drawn to it I don't know cat I see look
Jesus Christ so they did some terrible
things just stuff to these hippies I
mean they wrote in on the wall helter
skelter and die pigs and I was watching
something on [ __ ] KTLA yesterday and
they were shown the evidence the Charles
Manson there opened up the evidence they
had the rope from the way they put
around Sharon Tate's neck they did
oh they're brutal [ __ ] the museum at
death that's where it's at that's some
dark stuff yeah I don't like that stuff
Hollywood Boulevard what am I going
I'll look it up yeah interesting I've
had a couple of girlfriends that have
been obsessed with serial killers and
they say that women are more obsessed
than men because what I want to know
about it cuz are you arm yourself with
information are you ever fascinated with
that cat mmm
yeah there was a hot minute where like
for entire month I would do nothing but
watch a series of documentaries that I
found on YouTube and I would fall asleep
to them about serial killers like the
the guy
would follow around people the LA area
the night Dominic stalker get stuck
stuff like that Charles Manson dude that
lasted for like the Richard Ramirez
could look at guy to have seen it wasn't
bad looking now he got a lot of love
letters and and marriage proposals a lot
of the what's really [ __ ] up is mostly
serial killers they get all these yeah
they get all these like women who want
to marry them they want to marry the
boogey man so you just got into the
Rodriguez one yes I just I don't
understand how somebody can do [ __ ] like
that yeah I think I'm drawn to because
that like ghosts and all that Bigfoot
that stuff doesn't scare me but this is
like the scariest thing Paul he would
take out their eyes he'd kill couples in
their bed when they were sleeping in
yeah and he'd make the men lay down on
the floor with like he would put stuff
on there are no that's the yeah that's
the you know that's that's not that's
the guy who loves amo yeah that's the
Riverside guy he'd they caught him he
would put a coffee he put like a saucer
and a coffee like a saucer with tea like
a with a cup and he'd say if if it
rattles if it even rattles I'm gonna
kill you
so the guy would have to sit there lie
there while he'd the guy he would rape
his wife and next to him or his
girlfriend yeah he was a psycho
sometimes he'd kill him sometimes he
wouldn't good guy cop by the way was a
cop for a while and they finally caught
him he's old enough is so terrible you
know like we did like with this thing or
like the Charles Manson exhibit I was
like I really want to add to that you
know so there's a morbid fascination
Kate stuff is so tragic man yeah but
there's this morbid fascination with you
know what we're terrified of we're also
you know why do we go to the zoo and
watch look at Tigers when they're
sleeping because we know they can rip us
to pieces you know we don't want to go
see at an antelope because we don't give
up a [ __ ] about it because we can kill
them I don't know why they have those
things would you see a polar bear and
you're like that thing would fun can eat
me I'm food and shoes that's so
interesting
yeah why do people grab your ears
because you're so big and strong
like a man bear thanks wrinkles wife did
you know a Lynx wrinkle inks don't call
me wrinkle inks you don't show you I
mean you would like it cuz you used to
watch football but uh the Hard Knocks is
back it's [ __ ] good and there's star
receiver Antonio Brown it's the best
receiver in the league he's always like
had a troubled past he's a diva he gets
there and he refuses to play because he
has he said first he went into one of
those cold chambers without the socks
you just went in barefoot you always
have to have booties on there's a reason
for that so he got like you know
frostbite all over his bottom of his
feet Jesus so he can't run and now he
the NFL has new helmets right so to like
make concussions not as bad and he
doesn't want to use it you want to use
his old helmet so they're like no yeah I
used the new helmet so now he's not
playing because he's not wearing a
helmet he's there only five receivers
always been nervous oh he's such a
monster so fast oh just so goddamn good
crazy though crazy but that the the Hard
Knocks is pretty great but the problem
is is the coach on their Gruden he
cusses a ton you know and it's so
censored you know the way hard-knock
shoots at HBO the team sees it before it
releases because they don't want
anything get out that they don't want
out into the public so they tell you
what to cut out and they make Gruden's
seem like a [ __ ] saint but he is a
[ __ ] he's a sailor dude oh my god
he's as hard on these quarterbacks but
he's oh no he just editing was back
coaching oh yeah I thought he didn't
want to do now oh yeah he's back for the
Raiders but they edit it like he's like
good job buddy keep it up and it's like
come on man
it'd be so much better if they showed
the real yeah this one's a [ __ ] so
awesome yeah he's great I thought he
didn't want these guys get sucked back
into it though
yeah how could you not what would Bill
Parcells is doing is he an owner of
anything or a manager no I don't think
so and what's crazy that you that show
on Netflix last chance you on the first
season there's a kid from that you know
they take like rejects from like
Division one stuff they go to Community
College and
that last chance you there's a kid from
there who's a stud but he is lazy and
then you see him on Hard Knocks he get
he kids he he went to somewhere like
Alabama and now he gets a shot on the
Raiders and cuz he was lazy at the
Community College and then you see him
in the NFL camp and I was telling my
girl a Mike I'm like cuz she shooting
like football she likes last chance you
and hard knocks and she goes oh that's
the guy who kept [ __ ] up in Community
College ago
watch what happens if he tries that in
the NFL she goes why don't you just
watch watch if he even hiccups wrong
we'll see what happens so there it's the
like the first week at camp and they're
in the dog days you know and he goes I'm
like my foots killing me and he's like
well yeah push do it amazing no I can't
go they go oh cool they caught him
literally like they caught him see yeah
just shows them taking his jersey out
there not like see you my girls like
what the [ __ ] I'm like oh no they don't
play man they don't give a [ __ ] yes she
you're not drafted yeah you just you're
panicked at how it is or my wrap it up
or do what every actor I did what are
you doing it's your shot like you have
if such a short leash and then you could
have battled through it but he's been so
like got some rise head and like
surprised now I told her I'm like watch
what happens when he tries in the NFL
I'm sorry but Gruden goes let's get
these guys gonna play the [ __ ] out of
here and literally an hour later he's
not a plane back though you know it's
it's not a popular thing to say but for
the most part I'm gonna say 90 set I'm
older now 97% of the time when you see
somebody who's not doing well or doing
really well it's a hundred percent their
fault
ten percent I don't give a [ __ ] boy you
know I'm sure lots of things happened
I'm sure you did what you see is that
these are patterns of behavior and
patterns of behavior or it's a habit
it's a habit it's a little bit like when
somebody says that guy's a pedophile
what but then you see it's not just one
kid it's a history of it it's 50 kids oh
yeah I mean you know these are these are
patterns of behavior that I've been
repeating themselves forever and your
choices are always shitty like you got
dealt with the healing real quick see ya
bye bye
macton teaches but here's what here's
like Haroon says inside he opens the
show with this he goes he was here's the
thing he goes you got to end somebody's
dream you gotta take the job you gotta
take their heart you guys clear about
the NFL it's the NFL that's exactly
right you're literally put like it's not
a team thing like you gotta take that
showbiz this is no different in a lot of
ways it's like this hey what happened
your whole family died in the fire
suppose about next it's called next we
don't need you would you just move out
of the way I'm sorry that whatever
happened whatever it will happen we got
too many people waiting in line well it
doesn't matter their life is the bottom
up know that comp you're young and
missing he's that way next time he's the
exact same horse it is I was talking to
the guys that's NAT brand they're saying
so while it got up there here it is up
here they're saying this guy was mad
because on the marquee they put an older
picture I'm not a newer picture and put
him on this side not this side and he
sold 60 tickets for six shows and they
just canceled the show and he blame them
I'm like no it's it's never the club
it's never ever so ever blame anybody
like that I don't blame anybody it's the
picture you put a picture of a fight you
could picture of Harvey Weinstein say
jokowi's then he's gonna sell out 16
shows it doesn't matter man yeah a joke
that yes he earned that [ __ ] and and sat
in the cut for a long this is new for
Joe it wasn't until he figured out a way
to get his special on Netflix by a hook
or crook by the way because they kept
saying no to him well he paid for
himself and there you go the other thing
is yeah so whatever whatever you did but
you know what you know Jo koy does too
and I do press now - he does so his
shows are all sold out everywhere sold
out he still does breath
why do you press he is why wouldn't I
yeah so
I'll take that too but I don't like to
impress I hate it i I do press now I had
to close my contract no press just stuck
jo koy I do press ma'am there you go
even when the show song it's just in
your approach it's called heaven where
you go it's called going wait that works
you do that I'm gonna do that yep
there's a huge thing about copying
successful people to the ends degree I
don't know why more people don't do that
just what
wouldn't you watch what they're doing if
it's working for them just copy them
that's what Kevin Hart said that's what
I did with Dane Cook
I'll watch Dane Cook I was like I'm just
gonna do that I'm gonna go collect all
the [ __ ] email address Kevin at every
one of his shows you'd have somebody
would walk around and get their email
addresses and he just had a bank of the
mountain jo koy had I mean he wants
people have like something physical to
take home with Liars like what's flyers
Wow
he I mean this is the way does merch if
you buy enough merch you get into the
VIP or you can just buy her the VIP the
whole experience call by Mark she
doesn't press and he sold his whole
thing was prizes he meet people after
the show he just does VIP and if you buy
$75 more merch you get automatically
getting VIP oh because he has so many
shows you can't can't be there come any
people can you meet I mean that's hard
for him oh yeah he's just seen those
people he does two shows a night uh yeah
two shows a night 16 shows yeah it's the
interested in being around him just see
it I don't know why they up to me that's
that stuff's priceless man to see how he
does I slice I'm learning right now
level it's priceless can't wait to get
back on the road yeah
priceless cat what'd you do this weekend
not much I was sick all week with what I
have no idea I think it was a cold but I
just told ya
chin what'd you do what did I do
[Music]
no I literally wrote it down so I
wouldn't forget this time yeah all right
first you have an island uh I bought a
bunch of come on me I'm seen you killed
your apps name no but I bought this
ramen on Amazon but it's super expensive
instant ramen right so it's thirty seven
dollars for five pack bring it up please
it's so delicious though how much it 37
bucks for a five pack you brought up in
common you bought wrong it's like stop
robbing no it's it's based off of a
really really famous place in Japan
called each year on we were to eat your
own ramen never have not but let me see
it please see you bought you don't write
this down you got in computer and bottom
make sure I didn't forget this time
eater on CIA dude what do you know
and downtime because I don't buy that
you're in it how much is it oh this is
not the one like this one here forty
thirty seven it was 37 when I bought it
now it's 39 so is it just noodles with
the seasoning
it's the broth so it's in like a few
packs there's a 1 2 and then a 3 so you
got to do it together and then there's
straight noodles that you boil
afterwards and put it in in this nice
it's if you guys like Japanese ramen
like I restaurants huh never this is
literally the closest thing you could
ever get to the ramen is made what is
the ramen broth broth yeah come on yeah
but what is you know what is the what
are the noodles are they rice noodles
are they flour
I don't know right rice though huh
can I say something and hopefully
they're thinking wrong wake young me and
my brother are very young I said we were
like five and six just eat a ton of top
ramen yeah and I used to always get the
shrimp one and then I would open another
shrimp one and I put two packets of
seasoning in it so it's real strong I
put hot sauce over the top and my
brother you know he's me older brother
mean older brother he goes hey you know
that seasonings Asian dudes sweat that
they drop yeah you say this and I might
and never slid on hard to eat oh no hold
on I haven't had it since yeah I was six
yeah that'll ruin you there never had it
since I was right favorite yeah it was
my favorite yep and jegos that's dried
up sweat from an Asian dude they just
crumbs really yes it is I was hunting I
was hunting with Rogan done
I was honey was my buddy gave me he's
part owner Ana in a protein bar company
and the protein bars were made from
Buffalo no dog no good protein bars were
made from something high in protein I
know I was disgusting what crickets
right crickets yeah oh yeah and I was
and I was and at one point I was like
I'm gonna do this and I'm hunting you
know I'm eating the cricket dust and it
broke into dust
hey ground up a bunch of rickets and I
have
I just went [ __ ] this I don't wanna take
my buddy go hey [ __ ] your company [ __ ]
your stupid bars now this is never gonna
work
I just say there's a lot of protein in
like insects but funniest don't [ __ ]
with it okay but I don't have to do you
can go to the market there's Islands
above but a commercial for on it right
now because I had the on it health bars
that I brought a bunch of the on akele
bars and those Oprah's another day where
I was the only one who brought a
shitload everybody was fighting for them
after a while they're like would you
have any more of those [ __ ] Buffalo
bars there's a bar you know but dude oh
the big dip seems that and of course
Rick EXO cricket protein but you can
bring up like the Asian markets they
stuff like deep fried roaches and oh
yeah it'll suck suck in scorpion anytime
you have a country where you like any
time you're in a situation where there's
not a lot to eat you eat whatever the
[ __ ] you can get your hands on boy they
eat you know you can be pretty much
everything in the sea everything
seaweed shrimp there's nothing you can
almost nothing you can eat certain
Blowfish if you get the wrong one you'll
die right away when you eat it but can
eat jellyfish what's that can't eat
jellyfish yes you can you can again look
at that these are delicious - what are
those I don't know what that is I dude
and krykus I thought it was your head
my son bought a bearded dragon nice to
have one of those you got to eat well
it's a giant lizard the [ __ ] thing
eats the [ __ ] thing eats 12 crickets
five mealworms and for five [ __ ]
super warm those crickets chirp later we
put one of the mealworms in with the
super worms the super worms are like so
all the super worms these giant brown
like they look like bees caterpillar
like they move around so in this little
[ __ ] mealworm this little bait white
one
all of them all five we're like kill him
they just they just went home and ate
the [ __ ] out of him he was just gone and
then that and then the gag the bearded
dragon came and went ate em all sticks
his tongue out them him they eat they
they eat ants and Australia Australia
better than that
Australia Colombia Thailand stinkbug
Mexico South Africa make sense high in
vitamin true answer like a boat Cambodia
Venezuela mmm termites Jesus Christ I
don't you often go on date that aren't
you
no it tastes like crab well nobody in
crab what I was told to that it's like
soft-shell crab what's the weirdest
thing you've ate get boiled all things
blood like a pig blood jello I was a fan
of it oh my god do it don't do it what
about you - I love that by the way pig's
blood it's disgusting it's really good I
think maybe large intestine means large
intestines it's not too bad it was the
filled with it's just literally that
it's that tribune piping yeah why are
you that it was delicious
Asians are really into texture yeah I
need grubs I guess grubs what's one
thing EVP I'll tell you I didn't eat it
I physically can't but we were that egg
the poop dog yeah what is it
what don't means or you could pronounce
it better okay all right bullet bull a
bullet mm-hmm but not disgusting
it's grazing I mean the one I got you
guys was terrible because it was raw
still I didn't know I'm supposed to cook
it I don't want to eat that that's a
baby bird now it's just intestine we're
seeing evasion
there's gotta be other stuff but I just
don't remember I bet Playboy you've
eaten intestines you I bones
well try the chicken bones I like lining
you'll like it cooked well enough I'll
use everyone the bone I'll eat
everything brains I will not eat you
that sounds great to me too buddy reins
[ __ ] I try I start sucking out the
marrow but then I end up being the
entire bones if it's brittle enough if
you cook it well enough it's yeah human
bones are what do you kind of own up
there
he's so weird chin well that's how I get
rid of the bodies you know that bone I
think it's good chicken wings that's
probably why my parents and everyone
would have liked this ridiculous like
they don't get sick from eating healthy
from eating bone consider I'll do
anything I'm super healthy yeah I mean
meeting everything like intestines liver
horrid Sumer and a runny nose no seven
hours a day but was lost I heard me
sniff this morning no yeah well kratom
and bones cracking bones yeah I'll tell
you what I can't I just the texture
stuff like
get down I can't eat eel anymore do you
want know how much keto I am - my god I
ordered our favorite our favorite sushi
sugar fish and I got what they call it
what's the thing news hour
news hour they like make it truck you
that trust me no vodka and I just ate
the fish shut up and have the warm rice
I speak the fish dude rice is so good
luck in 2:35 come in oh thanks strong
all right now very first hard for you no
it's not dude I don't think pop we can
get this pop is a giant Samoan your arms
look better than ever ever seen them
look I swear to God
yeah got long big arms
what's your reach jack I don't know
don't call me jack you've never had you
annoys me you don't worry those Gucci
boots we bought but no I'm these are my
starter boots and I'm wearing the Gucci
ones it they're just I just get they're
a little shiny and they have that band
they're nice but I get nervous
god I wore them I was with Luke Rockhold
and he goes he goes those are shiny I go
they are he goes but I like him and I go
you don't like him you're saying that he
goes no they're good I wouldn't wear
them with those jeans you got a got a
dress him up yes might get one of those
jeans yeah I got some ideas I'm gonna
start you'll see I'm gonna start killing
it killing it those are weird too
I have a lot of those boots you're a
dandy I have those all right let's do it
what's a dandy a flower did you watch
the fights law no you didn't watch me
there I didn't even know they were on
how about that I was talking about on
below the belt I feel like the like the
lust and like the excitement for the IFS
he's just not there anymore I feel like
he's not fill more time at this Todd's
like dude I can tell you fighting
anymore what is the biggest fight you
excited about go I mean I'm looking
forward to this tea pie fight no meat
meat - but anything or a fight where you
will stop everything to have people over
and watch it's not there I would watch I
would john jones dcadt heavyweight
trilogy that that would be cool that's
not having them
that that I'd watch and I want to see
the first Inca bead that would be very
interesting Connor coming back Chiron
won't come back Willie I don't know but
I'm just saying now you know I don't
want to see kind of come back but I do
want to see like it would stop could be
you'd have people over copy Ferguson
that would be amazing I'm saying like
style pen or Whitaker is I'm excited I'm
not gonna stop my plane right or it
right exact like I used to stop my life
for certain cards it's just I don't know
man and the ratings are kind of thing
what I'm saying yeah yeah I think it
goes back to having to you have to
create a story around you know your
fighters and they have to be yeah but
they've been around for years and
ratings are down so you know they're
doing it I just I don't know I agree I
agree let's do some current events all
righty
mmm first one sports go through that
don't they didn't basketball go through
that and then bird and all those guys
came along yeah there there it watches
and wanes once you get some superstars
in there it's like whoa you know know
what's this this is so interesting to me
I saw this that distinct to you guys cuz
no one's talking about it do you
remember Mike Posner you know a song you
wouldn't but you cooler than me took a
pill in Ibiza you know that Jim Wow
so so he was go ahead cat good so he
decided that he wanted to walk across
the country starting from New Jersey he
got a good distance away he was
averaging about 20 20 miles per day and
he ended up getting bit by a rattlesnake
and he was told that he would probably
never walk again and Oh crazy girl what
after consistently trying with day and
day out he finally started to walk again
he says a couple week I poison will
literally deaden you right the nerves
but how crazy it took a pill in Ibiza
took the walk and now he's Forrest Gump
in Milwaukee and [ __ ] got bit by a
rattlesnake huh I don't know where did
he say where yeah bit I've been on the
west coast yeah like
you gotta give East Coast as dogs we'll
get paid since my friends are my friends
Colorado he got bit in that the arm in
that that his arm didn't that dog's arms
dead never worked again yeah that's
whatever lifted just in time he had he
has some hits - so hon music Mike Posner
had ambitious goal a nine months 3,000
mile walk across America but also Mike
make music dude that's what he was doing
though he was making a song in each
place that's what I heard
well this is the best it was he gonna
make a full recovery do we know as of
right now he's looking really good to
make a full recovery
nothing has been couplet what up doe
crazy day yesterday I had just crushed
60 miles and was going for eight more
when I got bit by a baby rattlesnake the
venom is no joke I got the hospital and
got the anti vitamin time a baby round
stink binami this [ __ ] up because
nobody rattlesnakes have more
concentrated loaded and they have more
so big rattlesnakes will give you a dry
bite sometimes they won't use all their
venom baby rattlesnake will shoot it on
your body so it's a good day to be free
this is a little snippet of my Colorado
border song play it let's hear this what
a great idea yeah I like mike posner
he got a dick on michael Chiesa he makes
some jams man and he can't breakdance
really but whatever he's hairy so every
state he goes to he makes a song that's
great man I think so the bid oh man you
can't walk anymore it paralyzed him
it'll paralyze you that that venom will
[ __ ] your nerves were ever so it's what
attacks the central nervous system right
it's it's a neurotoxin gun hero zero
toxin meaning your nurse your
neurological system play that one chin
it's hard to explain what I got the
vision fo it's almost like I'm trying to
sing a hit and note and I can't even get
it outdoors in my throat I get so
frustrated I feel like a misanthrope I
start feeling like my whole life isn't
dull still urban have another doll this
scene with what I didn't know [ __ ] my
father told me starts hitting home
the [ __ ] my even here at live info I
miss my friends we don't talk as much as
we used to
I'm too busy checking on YouTube is
scrolling on IG I tend to get glue to
various distractions as my life blows by
if I was black I'd be like white people
copy us a lot no I like you like the
black they don't care what the idea of
woke can't that hole that rattle they
make it easy why people are always go
right and they're stupid
no no no go down what's his other videos
what's then I'm a butterfly flying
through a broken Scott
I survived more fun than I'm open what
it takes courage to be still and go
inside I'm on the hey man this round I
kind of [ __ ] him up huh
well he got afraid you got super urban
okay there's some big hits did you
[ __ ] marry him you know what wrinkles
Conor I repeat I have pretty good hair
now I'm on TV all the time
look at my hair it's not bad for a guy
who was losing it you know I thought
they're using computer-animated I'm glad
I've said that technology there do you
know who's a customer of for hems who
gets their finasteride who gets their
hair pills your little Bryan Callen oh
yeah been a customer of four hems now
for a year almost think of you started
five years ago you look so much well
bottom line it comes to my eye you know
how I got my hair pills didn't have to
go to a doctor no picture of my hair
filled out a questionnaire a real doctor
looked at it and they send me my pills
in the mail I never run out and I used
to pay so much money for the for the
brand and now I get the generic from for
hems at a fraction of the price and
here's a customer you are dude and you
look good I don't feel the best folks
know whatever 66% of men lose their hair
by h35
bro for hams calm a one-stop shop for
hair loss skin care sexual wellness for
the bro PP with your dong dong little
you know a little bit flaccid you want
him ten-hut as it gets you want on the
carve class you want a turbocharged that
they got the pills for that too PP
listen you guys get
a month of hymns for just $5 today right
now while supplies last
no doctor visits none of that stuff see
website for full details safety
information this would cost hundreds am
i right be with the doctor pharmacy get
them for five dollars just for the trial
month all right man go to for hems comps
last fighter that's fo r hims comm slash
fighter for hems comm slash sleep and
exercise two very important things sleep
and exercise but it's Avery tracking
your sleep who's tracking how well your
workouts are doing for your body but
your heart rate or putting on about your
heart heart and everything else who's
tracking that I'll tell you how many
hours of actual sleep you get I'll tell
you is go ahead time out whoop oh whoo
there it is WH oo P the strap you put it
on you wear it 24/7 and measure your
heart rate 100 times per second 24/7 I
swim in mind it's easy to charge
attraction recovery ability yeah resting
heart rate everything and it gets
detailed man with your recoveries you're
sure right well I told you guys this I
was riding a bike thoughts burn all
these calories it told me I was burning
this many whoop really got down to the
nitty-gritty when we actually was off by
400 calories at least it was like you're
burning this many because it tracks your
heart rate resting heart rate your max
heart rate calories per second
everything but also attracts your couch
throughout the day just living breathing
walking you're burning calories this
tracks it your sleep in orange sleep
yeah but even sleep cycles it measures
your REM sleep your deep sleep in your
light sleep yeah they just he'll wake up
through the night it's fantastic and and
it what I dig about it too is it has a
five day battery life I'm in charge mine
yet I've had it way long in five days it
has a life heart rate monitoring it has
a dope band so it looks cool
the connects your phone bluetooth you
can track it whenever you want I'm
telling you man all you got to do you
subscribe to whoop
you download the app it's a monthly
subscription nothing will give you more
detailed about living a healthy life to
the fullest if you a keto kid this is
super important I've been on it and I
swear by these freaking things I swear
so right now just go to whoop calm
that's wh 0p calm use the code fighter
for $30 off a woo membership and enjoy
kin the Shred city with your boy
population 1 look guys you're looking at
me right now if you're watching this and
you see you see the glow you see how
young I look I don't age dude I get back
to the 7 they're like Brian what them
how the [ __ ] you look so young
well I don't know it's called on it dude
I got all my nutritional optimizing
potions I need yeah and juice real
emotions how do you think Brian
remembers the script he's on alpha brain
that's correct it writes my dad that's
my why is my breath smell so damn good
got health cuz your guts right man's
right and they just sent me my battle
ropes cuz you know me I'm the keto kid
now I'm down some weight but I need on
its help they got everything
ropes a keto kid yep I got the battle
ropes gets red city population me and
you guys we got joint oil glutamine
creatine electrolytes the total Kido
baby baby assaulted Waterman watermelon
I use melatonin spray how about there
are so nutrients whatever you need man
keto kids let's take it by the horns a
credit you ever done the shrimp tech
hell yeah I've done the SH I swear to
God I swear to God the shroom tech I
take that [ __ ] and I'm like why after my
work and I'm like why am I still have I
have crazy energy that [ __ ] is the best
thing I've ever taken that stuff makes
me crazy shroom tech mmm I take you out
for brain I feel like I ran out of my
shrimp to feel like Elon Musk go to on
it calm slash fighter and get
temperature off the entire dam site from
supplements to workout gear everything
jump on board right now it's on it calm
slash fighter you're welcome
37 million views is that good this is a
[ __ ] collect
he's a big deal after Bob John thing are
you just a hater
everyone's influenced by somebody dude
know what give me one of his other songs
oh you got no future so when you said
influence I found another Ed Sheeran
song then I'll play free house
it's an older ones now I want to hear it
I want to hear I'm ginger nuts I want I
think Chin's right about this I don't
how about I think you know he's the most
successful why don't you marry him to
singer in the world marry him do you
know this song I'm sure you guys watch
this let's do this already I'm already
on schism you know this Roy stones are
great we gonna make Jagger's how many
girls thinking buzzer come on estimate
guess yeah we're ten days all of them
all of them all the girls
okay what about it so all right let's
look at sure here it's Britain 2014
let's yeah yeah cheering down day man
that's a that's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I mean hey hey we on top crabs dude
crabs I mean like this oh this is this
was different
yeah but no I hear an Eritrean is legit
ed Sheeran no he's amazing I just wish
he would just do well why don't you get
your hair dyed red and be the [ __ ]
Korean edge sounds like a lot of
haterade hey what kind of top ramen was
it seasoned with hate roast [ __ ]
Monday [ __ ] although we're
doing a ketose toxin no rice I can't
believe uh yeah I don't know people are
just reaching for eggs yeah paratime
yeah those dumb hats okay excellent
so Chase Bank has begun to actually
cancel all the debt from their Canadian
clients because back in 2018 they start
to shut down credit cards over it in
that country and they want to get out of
that country altogether and so they just
forgave everyone's debt to get out of
the Canadian
market yeah no hold on Chase Bank has
confirmed will forgive all outstanding
credit card debt for its Canadian
customers as if we need another reason
to be jealous of the great white north
the us-based Bank made the decision more
than a year after it retired the Amazon
and their plastic cards in Canada was
initially part that all Canadian card
holders would continue to pay off their
bouts however chase confirmed to USA
Today that is wiping all debt that's
amazing that's fair that helps a lot of
people out are you kidding that's cool
mmm tight move Barry Sanders like told
ya type move what else yet so Apple has
opened up their ah hacker requests to
the public before it was a couple of
people that they would invite to try to
hack their new iPhones in order to see
how they can combat future hackers and
what they found is that just just what
they were doing wasn't working because
they didn't have a large enough range
with her yeah well with their hackers so
it was stated that a secret company
reached out to hackers to see if they
could hack into Apple's database and
they were willing to pay 1.3 million
anyone do it people did try to do it but
anyone get successful on the articles I
read it says that there weren't anyone
who came out and said that it was
successful but they're guessing there
was somebody who did it not just said
hold my photo so my iphone my iPad got
stolen out of my car mm-hmm my iPad pro
but there's a code so you have to get
into it yeah Jerry erase it or just
change your password no but I mean how
are they gonna know my password they
can't get in you can guess it yeah they
can guess it there are a couple of ways
I think I didn't try to figure it out
but what they're trying to do is they
will reward 1 million dollars to anyone
who could actually go in and hack an
iPhone without having the person who
owns the iPhone to do anything so it's
not like you have to like press into
something log into something and then
you just steal their password that way
all right
so if you can remotely hack somebody
else's eye
or I bought iPhone they will give you 1
million dollars well it's open to the
public
I'll try my best I gotta wipe my iPad
clean I guess if there's stuff you don't
want on there well can't they charge it
with Apple pay and all that why would
you just reset your pastor no matter
what I did no no I what I'm saying is
that my iPad got stolen but my password
they'd have to get my present
complicated you make it a little bit
complicated oh sure did then then
definitely wipe it out
yeah you should wipe it younger what
else you got here you go so this video
is going viral it's just a good act from
it boo driver York uber driver gifts one
of our passengers in need with a new
outfit all right so you don't gotta wait
till Christmas okay was this whole
chocolate angel but that's your dress
you can wear it to church
it's from Old Navy and then here's a $50
Visa gift card so you can take that and
get your house shoes and you're wrong
when it's time okay that's very sweet
and people like that dude I mean should
I spend on drugs well I love people like
that let's be real
Brandon don't ruin a good time just this
thing you're being mean and I don't like
him like the Internet I just hate on
everything and I have to go hey do me
let me ask you a question you're my
friend you make a lot of money yeah bro
don't ask you I'm gonna ask you on air
what I'm an ass gunner off dude don't
please don't be I'm gonna ask your honor
and I'm being really serious I'm being
serious please don't do this
buy me an iPad Pro
really yeah I mean how much are they I
don't know get up buy me an iPad Pro
birthdays got I want one and I don't
want to spend the money I don't know why
no your likes I've been giving a lot to
charity lately $5,000 yeah that's a
bigger one I want the bigger come on
just buy it for me go come to with me
and put it on your credit card will you
or won't you sure buddy yeah there you
go there it is 870 now I want the one
though with don't be cheap about hey
you're gonna call right there let's do
it twelve point nine inch that's the one
that is the big boy I want I don't have
a lot you don't have a laptop or an iPad
let's go buy one let's go buy him after
this I don't you buy me one and you buy
yourself one how cool is that
that's a good deal I'll help you I'm not
gonna pay for it but I know you would
dig an iPad what does use your phone
mostly right iPads just like you know I
don't want the screen right you got to
be on it but you know what you can watch
movies when you're of a giant TV no but
when you're on the road get one and I'll
get one you whites you can watch
documentaries and I watch fight to watch
you disown let's go let's go after this
another screen we'll go after this you
buy yourself one get yourself a nice one
get me one into the [ __ ] of it cool you
make a lot of money man dude you make a
lot of money dude yeah but you have a
you're a CBD oil baron and I'm not say
Titan I'm not gonna say Titan but your
urinal you're a [ __ ] CBD baron you're
an oil baron you're an oil parent Oh
what else we have I gave a lot to
charity a lot to charity this past
[ __ ] three weeks like too much it's
embarrassing
but you know people need money and help
so I think I deserve an iPad as you buy
yourself one dude you just said you'd
buy one you just said you'd give me
$1,200 you know you know if we go buy a
iPad store well wearing what we do that
one show together the end of the month
no I want one
right before we move on you asked about
the la thing dancing exhibit yeah you
sent me this in the morning right yeah
so it said that it was here till 5:00
p.m. yesterday yeah and it'll be another
50 years till it comes back whoa
yeah so well there you go let's go I'll
be late for my set this someone sent me
some guy named Aaron I think it was
Aaron about Dave Matthews Band that's my
[ __ ]
right the timing is crazy almost 15
years till the date his tour bus dumped
800 pounds of human waste [ __ ] and piss
down a bridge in Chicago okay
down a bridge what do you mean so it's
no city what's right here on this bridge
I had been there supposed to you know
hook up to an actual sewage pump area or
whatever yeah but they somehow they
dumped here and this meter during that
[ __ ] River and there was a tour going
on during that time where a guy from the
right a writer from Chicago Tribune was
there yeah and they said that there was
stuff falling down that was yellowish
and brownish yeah smell-my Christ doodoo
baby people got sick yeah ticket are
their refunds and everything some even
more dude so honey where can I get some
vintage Dave Matthew Tour shirts man
that would be a bummer 800 pounds of
[ __ ] yeah and piss they probably ate a
bunch of deep-dish pizza or like let's
ditch this joy it's gotta go somewhere
right sold down it was there
dry ice management the other driver
pride do you think you think Dave
Matthews like yeah released the [ __ ] now
nah dude he's writing [ __ ] magical
trash waste management is very important
yeah so he got one and a half years
probation the band donated it says
50,000 but the amount that they totally
did was around $300,000 yeah three hubs
someone gave them $300,000 for dropping
[ __ ] on him drama someone left me a lot
of women paid prefer that a nice done
but at this very a DM before bus jump in
here pounds on pool on some people
hashtag never forget hashtag always
remember they did it really land on
people yes you got cyber turn on me I'll
be furious
[ __ ] that's now Spears from Dave
Matthews dude I just look up and go so
much to say so much to say so
much to say trash on you unto me dude
um to me who on to me alright alright uh
your boy Hulk Hogan he was given an
unauthorized ride from an airport
Chicago police officer that went through
the tarmac and it wasn't supposed to do
it but Hulk Hogan's manager was
videotaping it and put it online
accidentally so that police officer was
not allowed to do this but he did it
obviously because it's all Kogan serve
he if I'd let you know but they're gonna
revoke his whatever tarmac oh let the
officer off he was just doing a civilian
assault it's Hulk Hogan gotta love him
hey Jimmy Hart right god bless that it
god bless the Chicago PD and that
officer and Hulk oh god bless Hulk Hogan
sunglasses alright alright I saw this as
well Georgia Southern quarterback was
pulled over by police and then they saw
something on his hood that was a white
substance and they thought it was
cocaine and he was like no it's not
cocaine's bird poop right so they
arrested him
Wow he's a southern black end-of-school
quick what's that
Georgia Southern what kind of type of
school what any more type tech
technology all black all black
technology bike yeah well let me play
this real quick bird [ __ ] bird [ __ ] yeah
wait can we just go back to see how that
guy ran was he scurried over there he's
right that's not athletic
promenade and bird dude I swear to god
it's not because I just tested it and
that turned pain oh well they're lying
to you well I mean probably did turn
pink but it doesn't mean it's cocaine
it's just some stretch yeah how so he
what they did get him for speeding as
well but all the charges are dropped now
cuz he tested and it's not obviously not
cocaine let's do where these cops
thought birch and he was also suspended
from his team to it for playing but now
he's back on oh thank god that's
obnoxious and not cool but also don't
have Brittany guy dude how about last
night I drove the the Rory got the roars
I do your your truck is here I thought
you're gonna sell that [ __ ] my am I
am it's really annoying I know don't we
can park there anyway stricter Rory to
Brea and I got there before Joe and Joe
pulled I guess you know he's with this
whole squad and he has a Panamera and he
pulled up he you know you like car guy
didn't watch his cars but he pulled out
was like who the [ __ ] and then he the
[ __ ] is that like that's jobs and he and
my car's always clean I just watched my
cars he's a god damn and I guess he
wanted to park away from me yeah cuz my
car so clean someone could went went so
his team heard him say that we go inside
someone washed and detailed his car
while he was on stage Wow
yeah no one from Steam someone heard him
complain some agents you heard it and
cleaned this plane in detail to tell is
that that's also your what I like that's
insane Ferrari that's a true race car
it's actually got all the stuff in the
library I won't but it's I'm gonna call
it a fur and you got this fur
don't let the Fergie yeah you got the
Fergie and you drive it like it's a pon
de yeah I like that you drive it all you
like
oh yeah that's the miles yeah most
people keep it in their garage you drive
it that's your primary car that's my
date but it's not comfortable right I
mean so comfortable is it yeah to drive
that much yeah oh yeah dude aren't you
afraid it's too low and it's gonna get
run over by it ducks I'm not a [ __ ]
dude you're tesla's low which is low
it's um I mean get ran over by a truck
yeah my Tesla was fast and furious to
save her yeah so Rory dude sir are you
faster off the line than me yeah
probably
top speed you top out fast all right
about 240 yesterday my man no you didn't
don't drive that fast please don't do
that
sometimes on an open road late at night
you gotta take you am gravitation nobody
around
no go 140 I'll go 140 and it's no
problem at 140 that's so fast all we
could keep going papa that's so scary
them just because if I hit a pothole it
could be trouble for your boy what a way
to go [ __ ] dude
that makes me really nervous a hundred
and forty hours no don't do that
you know I was in a BMW and I hit a
[ __ ] mattress really fast and almost
well don't do that I well don't do that
it's also batteries I had a forgotten
middle-of-the-road Yahoo and I I was
like here goes but I went over it it's
never walked my carpet people can will
die because of that
oh yeah sure but don't be an idiot and
hit match with us yet gents that scares
me just now I'm scared a lioness in
Germany in a German zoo gave birth to
Cubs and then ate them Jesus in front of
the the caretakers what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
why so she actually took Karen for a
while but then so they're saying that I
guess in captivity this happens more
often but it's usually when they sense
that there's some something like a
sickness with their cubs but they won't
make it just end up oh wow
what happens way more capped is enough
fur it's like The Hunchback guy 300 you
don't want him around
damn you feel me be yeah I do sometimes
you gotta be dude nature's [ __ ]
nature's little rod sometime that nature
is metal Instagram page to turn that on
it'll ruin your [ __ ] mind
sometimes it's like it showed like this
bird like just holding this other
smaller bird down just caving it I saw
it out with the hey Jamal God he was
alive - wait what happened his pigeon
was literally alive and the The Crow or
something was just picking out of idiot
a lion I don't this one animal I hate
its Birds dude they're [ __ ] dinosaur
some are double their stupid looking
dude how about how about on life that
that show that dividend burro was the
the lungs and this baby
wael was not gonna make it and the
mother was exhausted she was she kept
trying to boo him up and keep him above
water so he could breathe and he's gonna
die and those sharks had already gotten
to it so all of a sudden the mom
disappears and I like the bay the mother
abandoned the baby because she couldn't
take it and you see these giant [ __ ]
sharks see what and tigers surrounding
they're coming up and they're like well
that's they this is the end for the baby
whale because they've been trailing they
knew the baby was sick yeah I don't know
where mom comes up and she brought with
her a huge long hail of squad and this
male blew bubbles around the baby and
then started jumping here and landing
where the Sharks were like cats are like
all right we're out of here the baby
survived yeah save the baby and then the
baby was harpooned by yeah oil and it's
meat and I approved it I approved it
what else you got since Brian mentioned
sharks there's a sad story but we can
pass it we can pass it is about shark to
get it's a very sad story though let's
hear it
girl got eaten by sharks yeah that's
like almost all eaten it's a 21 year old
girl yeah she just sucked up in Portland
scream there's another coming she was
swimming toward yeah the boat where mom
was so she had no arm at that time and
as she's screaming another tiger shark
came and took her leg and then she she's
like did you survive she bled to death
for thing
damn it took her arm then her leg yeah
[ __ ] things can bite right through
you matter that was she was gorgeous
yeah young - what a [ __ ] bummer man
she's 21 tiger sharks in the Bahamas
when - tiger sharks attacked her in
front of her mom yeah [ __ ] sakes there's
one right there
good god one took the arm though it took
the leg yep that's game over
why shan't TV down there though that's
this that's her girlfriend and her dad
she was a lesbian
I imagine cuz they called her a
girlfriend or is it just a friend as a
girl sorry just a friend
I buy a [ __ ] tiger shark the mothers
on that saw it so the mother was on the
boat when that happened
yeah just jump in the water what do you
do you I mean what do you do I think you
jump in the water yeah I think your
instincts will make you do that I want
to fight him
yeah cuz you go after the shark scroll
down said dad Michael told how his
daughter destory tried to escape after
she had almost her right arm ripped off
might do Tigers are the worst man oh are
you sharks she screamed in terror the
mom did risk her own life swimming
towards her to save her Michael who had
been with the rest of the family petting
pigs in there by way to go Michael
Kim said she heard Jordan yell mom Kim
looked back first thing she thought
where dolphins were around Jordan I
never think it's dolphins first fighting
back tears my cottage she's yelling
Jordan come swim to me the doors not
swim so good realizes the first shark
took most of her right arm off join me
to her mom but at the moment a second
chart struck ripping off her flag - I
wish survived the arm they're so nice
Lauri George said mom there's another
shark coming that just hit the second
chart hit like a caramel her leg just
took a giant chunk out her and then
that's the last hard [ __ ] sure it's
like the guy said you're in that urine I
window wilderness area and they could be
territorial that could be hungry dancers
from California mmm [ __ ] man that's
awful hmm I can't imagine alright well
ended on a happy note
sharks doing shark [ __ ] in it yeah
this girl posted a picture on her
Instagram saying an inspirational
message about getting out you know being
healthy and all that stuff yeah and her
sister called her out and said that she
took this picture in the backyard it was
an Instagram post session you did all
right
okay what's the problem hold on she lets
get line to me all right my sister she
was going hiking and this is our
backyard this she showed her sister well
having her friend take a picture why why
you red white red not here's the
original message she wrote nature's the
ultimate healer to all our problem
there's a water bottle and everything
okay but she's hot yeah she might have
been on her way to go hiking and she
just did this better back your French it
does look like nature though that's
nature I'm a fan [ __ ] it yeah [ __ ] it
person so this what what kind of cut US
history
yeah [ __ ] her sister's a jealous
[ __ ] and where's the sister at man
that's not her she's the one that take
he's taking the picture from all the way
over here why would she do it to show
that they're faking that picture yeah
but even who gives a [ __ ] I was gonna
say hey listen anyways this is the girl
look she's a double tap dancer let's
bring let's bring up let's make sure
everything's okay with the other picture
let me see this is her I'm very happy
where I'm I'm a huge I'm a huge nature
lover now say that much it makes me want
to go hiking with her let me see another
pic please she looks very young - I
think she's in maybe in college or not
she's at least in our 20s yeah with that
body she's at least 19 I mean that
girl's athletic land of the free home of
the brave got the quotes are terrible
aren't they she looks young yeah but
looks like she graduated here well leave
her alone Saint Mark Catholic Church
she's in high school bro that's a
graduation gown alright yeah hold a
sheath of chin I'm guessing she has to
be at least 18 I think that'd work it at
least I got a private jet in an island I
wanna wow that body for night can't be
my right God dang dude right there's
like kids dude stick in Jesus crime
buddy why did you say that in general
yeah I didn't know I I don't know why
just made me laugh so hard chin bring
this up this made me laugh so [ __ ]
hard hold please huh
sorry Instagram it's gonna be on Twitter
I'm a 39 influencer how many people does
she have what I saw she had like 3,000
or 4,000 I bet it's like him waiting for
now she gets all sorts of DJ double
didn't know got 8,000 followers it's not
a whole lot she'd have way more now
because this everyone she's super hot
I just sent teaching I don't know why
this made me laugh so hard by myself I
have no idea why but it's for to get my
suit oh my god would have known his way
would have would be hotter than Florida
hashtag late day hashtag summer I want
to start doing uh I want to do the
fashion thing line for men my age just
called wisdom and wrinkles wrinkles
should be you posing like this there's
been stupid quotes that's funny
you have to stage it let's do ring yes
buddy alright did you see the one eyes
yeah let's do it with a clothing company
hey your clothing coming to reach out to
me and Brendan will be my fashion
designer we'll call it wrinkles this
made me laugh so hard I don't know I
stopped wearing my other piece not we're
not a lot of people Adams like this
black girl is that it I'm sorry this
guy's hilarious keep going
no it's not it you know if the if that
there's a doughnut in it it's fantastic
if I get three A's in my a-levels
I'll take slap one of my boys and film
it I love this guy when you comparing
dick size with your boys and it's you're
6 foot 6 inch friends turn to get is
Miguel it's Keith roll down to I got it
I gotta know how to do this I mean I
myself change settings
what are you head since with my
daughter's I don't have any less stars
it's so aggressive dude my daughter well
he tends with my daughter I'd just
[ __ ] the girls hands though funny
[ __ ] board that's busted knockout
well there you go
he's prey end on that yeah now we're all
disgusted aren't we well we got a reveal
how we do on ticket sales we're doing
pretty well there yeah we're doing
really well alright guys come get your
tickets in Norfolk and see me and Brian
Oroville I will be this weekend Thursday
Friday Saturday Helium Portland with
Chappelle Lacey and Derek post and two
very funny
I mean Callen are in Oroville northern
Cali into the month one one show one
night only Saturday August 31st after
that I mean the Ice House passed a
Danish pasadena' pasadena and france ice
house you around we'd like to come back
come on buy ice house I'll get us our
that's September 12 and then I'm in
Houston September 23 21st Denver
September 26 to 28 Pittsburgh October
gets T fat cake ah good man thanks to
edit that's it dude this the funny kid
we're out